I am Obara son daughter of Oberyn
Martell Pacific Enoch who plays one of
my son and I Marius and her and I
remember the first day we got to sit the
two of us were holding on to its I was
shaking if it was so nervous and so
excited and we went and met and Nikolaj
and Jerome who played Bron and Jaime
Lannister and both of us completely
speechless no they come over sit are
high they're really welcoming nice to
meet you welcome we're super excited and
both of us has been ah yeah you're cool
and I think you know took a what took a
while for that to dissipate Paul gave
you the author say her name you found
out you were cast the night the mountain
and the Viper episode every what was
that like like that was planned your
life but we're gonna wait to tell her it
was over estranged and I was home
watching that episode and the red Viper
like it's such a violent death scene and
I found out that day that I was gonna
play a beerus and his eldest daughter
and i had such an emotional reaction you
know oh I wasn't expecting and I'd
totally fallen in love with his
character and my roommate at the time
actually it was very funny cuz I was
crying hysterically she came and she
said dude like it's just like it's just
a TV show like you should know that like
this was what you do that is my G need a
beard it when I'd find 1 million
non-disclosure agreements with HBO so I
couldn't tell anyone oh my god and so
it's all good you don't understand why
this is so important I'll tell you
someday